media outlets are panning that
performance as offensive and
others saying that nobody cared one
vanity fair writer even accusing the
comedian of repeating a quote
right wing talking point ricky gervais
however is hitting right back on twitter
saying how the bleep can teasing huge
corporations and the richest most
privileged people in the world
be considered right wing does he have a
point greg
number one ricky gervais isn't a right
winger he's a strong
outspoken liberal he doesn't like trump
but the thing is this isn't about right
or left
this is about freedom of expression and
i think what
what should be uniting conservatives and
liberals or whatever
whatever stripe is the riff that's going
on among liberalisms between free
expression
and those who want to silence people on
campus and that's where ricky gervais is
coming from if you read his twitter
twitter feed he is expressing his own
personal outrage
over the cancel culture about how people
are constantly being attacked for things
that they're saying
and that and it's very healthy that it
comes from him from somebody of the left
nobody no liberal is going to listen to
me because they're just going to say
fox news that guy he he trashes
everybody
and you know they're right but uh but
when he comes out
and he's upset ricky gervais is upset
because he's so confident in his liberal
ideas
that the refusal to listen to other
ideas
which is happening right now and the
regressive less
left enrages him it's a pathetic sign of
weakness
so it's a hard left that is actually
destroying liberalism
not not trumpism or not conservatism and
i think that's what's fueling his fire
and why he's so disgusted and angry
but do not mistake that for him becoming
a conservative
he's he's as liberal and the only
politics he's really into
and very strongly is animal rights this
is a guy who spends a lot of time
dealing with the you know the humane
issues with animals
but it's really about the rift between
old school liberals like juan
and the social justice creep that is
trying to silence people like juan he
also
i would agree because i've been muzzled
yeah you had a he wrote a book called
right so i understand what it is and in
that point i would say
yes yeah by the way i didn't even know
who ricky drew base was how dare you
he's the best
sitcom ever the office yeah i i just
didn't get it i mean
i mean but tyson you know around here
he's a star right now because of what he
did
but the question is one do you really
think that people
didn't make political speeches after he
spoke i think they did they
definitely did so i don't think it had
that impact i think the impact it had
was on
people who are conservative said finally
here's somebody voicing
but it's not a disdain for these rich
famous
arrogant people who want to tell us the
point though they're they're they're
criticizing
the hollywood elites are criticizing him
for right-wing talking points and he
said what about going after large
corporations
and and that's where greg and i agree he
shouldn't be muzzled and if
that was the point of what he did to say
this
is legitimate speech and it's free
speech coming from the left
hats off but the contrary the the
support for him is coming from the right
which
sees it as he was outside listening to
the dave chappelles of the world this is
about the mob this is about
people are so sick and tired of
everything in their life being
controlled
by their past or if they decide to take
a joke i have friends of mine the
majority of my friends are liberal they
tell me that they can't share
a post that they may agree from fox news
because
they'll get fired they won't be invited
to the next
get together or something because that's
how the mob works
and this is a guy who is a liberal that
just wants freedom of expression yeah
he's speaking out
against the mob but it's also about the
fact that what he said was true
he's calling them out on behavior that
they lectured the rest of america about
not doing while they engage in it and
it's about elitism
they're allowed to do whatever they want
while the people that they think are
not good enough or not rich enough or
aren't in the hollywood
liberal circles they're not allowed to
participate for but they have to be
quelled and do what they think is the
right thing to do whether it's climate
change or
health care or anything else like that
and ricky gervais is a liberal he is not
a woke leftist and i think this is
something that is pervasive throughout
comedy but also just
liberals in general on the channel today
there are people complaining about
woke leftists because they're saying
their reaction yeah he tweeted out best
reaction ever means a lot to me i had a
blast and thank
bleep it's over what did you think they
bleeped
there sandra oh no greg what is it wrong
nation